What I want to say is through growing
up,
what I've discovered is that this world
is a very vast of a wonderful and
beautiful one and there's so many things
to discover that the most important
journey I think all of us will go
through as the journey in ourselves to
find our truth,
to find who we are and what makes us
happy.
And in our culture
we are told that if we're beautiful,
if we skinny,
if we're successful,
famous,
if we fit in,
um,
if everyone loves us,
that we'll be happy,
but that's not entirely true.
Um,
and this is what I want to talk about.
Basically,
I'm going to start with a poem that I
wrote when I wasn't very happy.
Um,
I actually read this a year ago,
but again,
as if you know,
depression,
it comes back,
it's a reoccurring thing that you can't
really sought away anyway.
Who am I?
Who am I trying to be?
Not Myself,
anyone but myself living in a fantasy to
bury the reality,
making myself the mystery has strong
facade disguising the misery empty.
But we,
on the point of emptiness full to the
brim of fake confidence,
a God that will never be broken because
I broke a long time ago.
I'm hurting,
but don't tell anyone.
No one needs to know,
don't show or you've failed.
Always.
Okay.
Always fine.
Always on show.
The show must go on.
It will never stop.
The show must not go on,
but I know it well.
I give up,
I give up giving up.
I am lost.
I don't need to be saved.
I need to be found basically.
It's kind of just the same reoccurring
thing of uh,
yeah,
not knowing who you are and,
and feeling I again.
So yeah,
this started when I was about 15 years
old.
I was in school.
Um,
I really wanted to do well at school to
please my parents,
to please my family.
I didn't really care that much about
school because I knew I was never going
to be very good at it.
Um,
I think I pushed myself so far.
Got to the point where I had a bit of a
mental breakdown.
I was one of those people that just like
just did enough work.
Again,
I probably,
I,
um,
I have very bad learning disabilities,
so if you look at my writing,
it's,
it's not,
it's docketed adults.
Probably like a nine year old boy,
if you know what that looks like.
Um,
but I was just pushing past.
Uh,
yeah.
So I got to the point where I went a bit
mad.
I was completely suicidal,
didn't want to live anymore.
I thought that I was completely alone.
I also realize how lucky I was and what
a wonderful family,
wonderful friends I had,
but that didn't matter.
I wanted the wildest swallow me up and
nothing seemed better to me than death,
which is completely,
so I just got taken out of school.
I went to therapy,
got put on antidepressants,
kind of clawed my way back to some sort
of rational thought,
which took a while.
But basically I stayed in school until I
was 17 when I still was kind of played
with this depression and I was like,
I'm done.
I need to leave.
Which the rather large disagreement from
my parents,
I was,
I did,
I left and I knew I had to do something
because otherwise I would just go crazy.
So I started modeling.
There was elements which were fun cause
it's like this camaraderie of people not
being successful when you can complain
about all the people who are routine,
but it's not,
it wasn't nice.
Eh,
you constantly are told that you're not
pretty enough.
We're not tall enough.
I'm not skinny enough and people are
better.
And when you're young,
you think that means I'm not good
enough.
As a person.
Like that means I'm not living up to who
I should be.
And you kind of get battered and bruised
a lot,
but then you've kind of grown a bit of a
skin.
What would the agencies like?
What was an agency like?
Yeah.
I mean the thing with models is they,
eh,
you get used.
That's the thing I saw a lot of um,
misuse from photographers.
You know,
perverse photographers to young girls.
A lot of street photographers only
really do this because they want to
sleep with young models.
Um,
you know,
bad,
bad kind of experiences in that sense,
not by me,
but to other poor people,
poor girls who don't stand up for
themselves because you feel like you
should be used because that's what
models do.
Um,
um,
but then,
you know,
about a year into it,
I was discovered.
I did barbary and then everybody wants
you,
you know,
after so long of being like nobody wants
you suddenly like,
oh my God,
who's that?
I was like,
I've met you five times and it's pretty
useful.
You didn't want me two minutes ago,
but cool.
I had no concept of saying no to anyone
ever.
Um,
and this is one of the most important
show business lessons,
actually learning how to say no.
Have you learned yet?
Yes,
I think life.
You should always experience things,
but you should not,
you should say no.
I mean,
it's more about being control and not
being a puppet is what the most
important thing is and not doing
anything out and not doing anything for
anyone else apart from yourself.
Because after a while I just started to
get sick and I got this horrible thing
called psoriasis.
You look at yourself like you're an
alien.
You're like,
I'm so disgusting.
It's not good for your,
especially at that time I felt more
disconnected from myself than I think I
ever had,
which I was for a long time,
quite disconnected.
Um,
and as well,
well,
my agency,
we're like,
Ooh.
Because usually you have to take time to
fix internal problems.
Like it's food and stress and,
but you know,
they shoved me straight into a doctor
who would inject cortisone into each
spot,
which died them,
but not really in these,
you know,
that kind of thing.
It's like all those problems I had,
I feel like I masked with medicine
instead of taking the time to really
solve them.
But at that time I really wanted someone
to stop me.
I wanted someone to go,
you need to take a break.
You need to look after herself.
And no one did because I was the one who
had it all like I was.
I had what everyone wanted the of nappy.
Yes.
Yeah.
Who say would've.
That's what I wanted.
It was more like the external life.
I couldn't be luckier,
more blessed,
but the internal battles that were going
on or just,
I also felt like I never deserved any of
it.
I was living someone else's dream.
It,
this point is just about like being able
to show,
like pass the mirror at yourself and
really look inside for what you need.
And what happened was I eventually said
no and I eventually took a break.
But yeah,
so I said No.
I went,
I started writing.
Writing was something that really saved
my life again.
So that pro per and probably came out.
Then it was like I would write and I
would read what I'd written and it was
like someone else was talking to me.
I was like,
watch this,
how I feel.
It was a very strange experience.
Um,
and then after that I found yoga,
which was a huge thing for me.
I didn't cry a lot.
I thought emotion as a kid was a
weakness.
I thought that if you are emotional that
like,
you know,
that's like a parent,
like just a silly thing to feel.
And when I went to Yoga,
I went,
I started yoga as a superficial thing
cause I was like,
I want to be flexible and fit,
you know,
like coop yoga people are,
and I went in to my yoga,
my guru yoga person and,
and um,
he was like,
why you doing this?
And I told him why.
And he sat me down and we just started
chanting and I was like,
we not meant to be doing like whatever.
So I was chanting,
I was so angry with myself,
no god.
And I broke through something and I bust
into tears,
which I hadn't done in years.
And I looked at him and I was like,
what is wrong with you?
How dare you?
You're a monster,
why would you do this?
And he was just laughing at me and I was
like,
sure was crazy man,
what is wrong with you?
And he said,
if you add an have cried,
I would have been very worried.
And I was like,
okay.
He was like,
and also you realize that this is the
first time you've actually looked at me
in the eye.
And the reason why is because I knew
when I looked in his eyes that he saw
through me and he knew me and it freaked
me out.
But till this day I've been seeing him a
lot.
It's like finding,
finding people around you who have your
best interest at heart.
I have a lot of people around me who
were just softer more.
I gave them not like,
you know,
often looking after you and stuff.
So it's about finding people who care
about you and support.
Um,
and again,
I've now become them being able to be a
support for other people as well.
So in turn,
that kind of goes around.
When I was a kid,
I always wanted to change the world
because little kids think they're going
to be to Paris,
but I have so many messages in terms of
just young girls and how the mental
illness and depression is not something
to be ashamed of.
And I wish at that time I had realized
that other people go through it,
that I can talk to other people,
that you're not alone,
you're not an alien.
Um,
and you know,
my message has always been to accept
yourself no matter what,
to love yourself,
to embrace your flaws.
I think floors are the things that make
us special.
The cracks within us are the beautiful
parts that need to have light shed on
them otherwise that just left.
Um,
and also women are great,
that wonderful,
wonderful creatures.
Women are the bearer of life.
And I think it took an experience of
going to a talk by a woman who dealt
with so much.
Um,
you know,
and like all these women Harris,
so incredible.
Like the last talk,
you know,
I've watched her on Youtube and it made
me cry and we witnessed these extreme
experiences that happen to women
suppression and all these other things.
But really that happens every day.
And we're all used to it in the
workplace,
in relationships.
Women are constantly suppressed,
but it takes an extreme circumstance for
us to realize it because we're used to
it not always confuses me a lot,
but obviously I think we're changing
that now.
Slowly but surely.
But yeah,
just the point of like supporting each
other and reaching out and
communicating.
It's the most important thing.
So I want to help basically.
I Dunno how,
if anyone has any suggestions.
When I got my first audition that I
cared about,
I cried my eyes out cause I never
thought I was going to be taken
seriously.
I never thought I was going to be an
actor at all or a model or anything.
I think as well,
I have so many girls come up to me and
telling me that they want to be models,
which is fine.
It's not a bad thing.
I just think there's so much to do.
I just went to a wonderful talk about
um,
genetic engineering and neuroscience and
this man who was giving the talk
expanded these as like 10,000 kids is
from the age of seven to 13 who are
doing neuroscience.
They do these competitions and one of
the things,
and not doing things in neuroscience,
which haven't been,
which one done by him until he was like
30 like how quickly things like that are
changing and but they're not.
There is an awareness sport.
It's cool stuff like that,
that that sounds way cooler to me than
being a model.
But like no one really knows about it.
And I just think there are just so many
things I always say to and just dream.
Just dream bigger.
Go the president.
Just keep going up.
Astronauts that them.